- Sinnah, sometimes I get tired
of pursuing my passion of rapping.
I'm wondering right now,
should I take a break,
or keep at it; if so, how long?
I get afraid of falling behind.
Much love to you guys.
- [Stephen] Yeah, that's
a good question, Sinnah,
I think, um, you know, if
you love what you're doing,
whatever it is, rapping, let's take that.
You probably need to say,
are you really energized?
Are you fresh, are you um, really focused
on achieving your goals?
And invariably, there comes
a time where you kind of
run out of a bit of energy,
and you need to have a bit of,
kind of recharge and reflection.
So um, at those points, you
know, whatever works for you,
you can go on vacation, whatever, um,
get together with friends, you
go and see mentors, you know,
whatever it is that really works for you,
and then uh, and then I
think that's a great time
to reflect on kind of what's working,
fundamentally to still believe
in your big idea, um, and if you do,
what do you need to change to
make it even more successful?
And then you kind of can
get right back into it.
- This is an interesting one, cause we're,
we're just about to release
a video on Lindsey Stirling,
I don't know if you know Lindsey,
but she's, she's a violinist,
and she had one of the
top YouTube videos, uh,
for one of her songs, and
when she was doing violin,
she kind of got bored
of it, because it was
kind of classical and the same thing,
and she just really grew tired of it,
and she wanted to put it
down, and then she discovered
electronic music and Skrillex and DJs,
and all of these people putting
out beats, and she said,
"That'd be really cool
to combine my violin
"with the electronic beats."
And she formed a new thing
that hadn't existed before,
and that reignited her
interest and passion in violin,
and also helped her differentiate herself
and create one of the top
YouTube videos for music videos.
And so I'm wondering if there,
there might be something
like that in it for you,
where if you still love rapping,
but you're not, you know, you don't like
doing it the way you've been doing it,
or the way other people are doing it,
to explore, maybe combine it
with another passion of yours,
to continue to test the waters.
You know, if you look at The Beatles,
none of their albums
sounded like each other,
the first album was way
different than the next one,
and way different than the next one,
and people are like "Well, why don't,
"we like the early Beatles, why
don't you keep doing those?"
Well we've grown as people,
we don't do that anymore,
we want to do new stuff, and I think
that's part of every
entrepreneur, especially artists,
you have to continue to evolve
and test and try new things,
and so, if you're getting a little bored
of what you're doing, I'd say,
"How do I mix in something new?"
Try out a new project that
still involves the rapping,
but you can involve,
incorporate something else in it
to push yourself and see
if it makes you come alive.
- [Stephen] Yeah, I
think that's good, Evan,
I think also, if you're
really getting bored,
go and kind of, go, go round and listen
to rappers you really respect,
go and meet some of them.
Um, maybe, maybe think
about doing something
collaboratively with a partner,
cause it sounds like you
just need new innovation,
it sounds like you've got a core idea,
you love what you're doing,
but if you need to evolve,
there's loads of opportunities.